I'm the wasp I'm the worst I'm so much
worse than regular bees I'll sting you
and Austin you
I'll sting everybody cuz I'm a shitty
bee I'm the wise
I'm the wasp it's very hot in there hi
everyone my name is Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara Jessa and last night I
went and saw ant-man and the wasp or as
it should have been named the wasps I
went and saw this with Doug robb Barney
Walker and another family member of
theirs it was so much fun I love seeing
films with friends and people that I
know I usually end up seeing the tamra
just saw movies alone which is also
enjoyable in its own right but it's
great to see you with friends I had a
really really really good time watching
this film
I loved the comedy in it I really really
enjoyed it I thought it was a solid
movie that has some problems but overall
I really really really really really
really liked it though I do think it
might be a little polarizing to the
fanbase I've heard some negative
opinions on it that I did not think
about it all while watching it I loved
it right off the bat I have to say that
I loved the wasp
I thought that her character was great
it was the first female superhero in the
Marvel Universe to have like her name in
the title it was it was great she was
badass she was well portrayed and I
thought that her character was was just
really well done and then in that I
think ant-man lost a bit of what made
him special in the first I really
enjoyed his ability to think on his feet
his ability to use technology and and he
was like really like active and he he
was like Ant Man before he even got this
he's like a very cool character he
kind of lost that a tiny bit in this
film he was I mean more off just like a
comedic a side character which was a
bummer but definitely
take too much away from the film for me
obviously because I still really enjoyed
it and I was really personally looking
forward to the wasp obviously the cast
in this is incredible Paul Rudd
continuously makes me fall in love with
him every time I see him in something I
always I don't know why in the back of
my mind I'm always just like ah he's
okay he's fine but then I see him is
definitely like wait no no just Tamara
stop he's so great I loved him in this
and I I'm such a sucker for you know
chick flicks I'm such a sucker for
romantic comedies and this was not a
romantic comedy
it was delirious throughout most of it
and it also had some romantic aspects to
it but it was the perfect amount it
wasn't you know just it wasn't
centralized around their romance but I
really loved the moments with them and
they they were great the chemistry
between the two actors were just were
really lovely the comedy itself in the
film was so good I know that the comedy
and marvel films are kind of burning
certain people out I
oh my god somebody on Twitter recently
said that I was a like a casual fake fan
because I liked comedy in my in my
superhero films which is wrong but also
I understand that Marvel films have
gotten progressively funnier and funnier
and funnier and that's not true for a
lot of them like you know Black Panther
wasn't like this thor ragnarok and this
was a funny movie it felt lighter
comedy-wise it wasn't like the
quirkiness of guardians of the galaxy
and it wasn't like the in-your-face
comedy that thor ragnarok was it was
like a light fun comedy and it works
really well with the characters I think
the only character that I wish was
developed a bit more is the villain of
the film I don't even know that I would
call her a villain I I really enjoyed
her character she's definitely not a
typical villain she's more like a kill
monger level of villain invest where
you're like well I understand where
you're coming from girl but she's still
technically the villain I thought she
was awesome
I also know a lot of people aren't gonna
really love her I really really did
I thought her backstory was really cool
I wish though that her adult story and
her current story was a little bit more
built up her acting was just so so good
and so believable and even though I'm
like I don't know you that well like
you're not that well-developed
I still super believe what you're
telling me here I also thought it was
hilarious because she's like this this
being that her atoms aren't like fully
formed so she's like sifts through walls
I'm like she's always in pain and like
she's always like going like from solid
to not solid form but like her hair is
ombre I think that hilarious bit like
she took the time to like die half of
her hair blonde and like listen I feel
that that's what I'm all about
I'm in constant tragedy and my hair is
half blue so alright I will say that by
far this is my favorite Stanley carrier
by far it's so so funny the entire
theater erupted so the last movie
ant-man Paul Rudd he was put on house
arrest and he is in his final few weeks
of house arrest he's really looking
forward to not being on house arrest
anymore
you have Hank Pym and hope him and they
are both under the assumption that her
mother his his wife is still alive in
the quantum realm and so the story is
about trying to get her back while
ant-man is trying not to get caught
while helping them while the villain
ghost is here trying to fix her ghost
enos and then there's also kind of an
unneeded side story where there's like
this other weird villain who was pretty
pretty worthless in the film I didn't
find him funny or like engaging in in
any way that's where ant-man's like
security detail team comes in
and they brought a lot of comedy to it
as well everyone was so so funny
I've been avoiding it because I'm scared
cuz I don't know how to say her name
Evangeline Evangeline yeah so you say
your name Evangeline Lilly loggia Lost
Girl I really loved her as this role
she's like hard enough where she's such
a badass she's fantastic in the more
vulnerable rumble of vulnerable moments
and I just I had a really fun time
watching her as well some of the comedy
was just so effortless like in the
beginning he's still on house arrest so
he's there he's reading well I'll show
you he's reading the fault line and
weeping and it's hilarious a huge
eruption from the audience just really
really fun I also I recommend this book
this one is signed it's not for sale he
learns magic it's delightful and fun and
I know that it's gonna be a nice kind of
moment for people who just we all got
done with infinity war and it was heavy
and this was not in any way heavy at all
everything was it was pretty nicely
resolved to the point where at the end
there is a moment that's resolved and
it's like well that was that was
extremely convenient and hmm I wish it
wouldn't have been as convenient as it
was for you because my my Wow
did that all just fit into place or what
okay
I broke down in my notes I was like the
comedy is perfect it's not thor ragnarok
levels of comedy which i used to really
enjoy but i know a lot of people thought
it was too much but it's also not like
thor two levels of comedy it's like zero
it's actually never seen Thor - the only
one will film I've not seen I've seen
clips
don't make me I don't want to I wrote
down that I truly cared about everyone I
had such a good time watching the comedy
in this I had such a good time it was
such a good theatre experience
I I loved it I loved the the lightness
of it I don't think every superhero
movie needs to be you know this life or
death it was nice to have something
light though maybe that's because I'm
coming off of infinity more so like you
know if I see it in five years am I
gonna think the same thing I want to say
I will because I really enjoyed it I
feel like any light-hearted nice good
content that I can get these days I'm
just grasping it up I'm grabbing it and
I'm taking it and I'm running with it so
that's what I feel about this one I made
a video on my personal channel on how I
put this awesome foam wasp helmet
together so check that out if you're
interested I can't wait to see you all
next week
Hotel Transylvania 3 right oh good
is that all that's going out next week
oh good all right I'll see you next week
or will I okay I can't breathe
[Music]
you